hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on for tonight again
and today we're gonna be talking about
the new item that just got released into
for tonight it is called the portal 4
and it is basically a grenade that you
can build your own fort with today we're
going to be discussing the general info
about the portal fort then go into
situations on when to use and when not
to use it as well some interesting tips
and then to end the video with my
overall thoughts and opinions to see if
this thing is viable in Battle Royale
so let's get started so to start out
with the basic info the poro fort is an
epic rarity meaning purple the drops are
in stacks of 1 and can stack up to 5 in
your inventory at a time when the portal
4 is thrown a pre-made fort is
constructed instantly at the impact
point the portal 4 is made out of metal
and is three stories tall and the bottom
floor is a one by one with the door
entry with tires inside along for easy
access to the roof as going based off of
the general tips from the fortnight at
the game's forum page basically the
tires are going to be on the floor like
I said there's supposed to be a really
big pile of tires in the back and then
too many ones on the side for you to
jump up to the top for obviously this is
just a four item so it doesn't do damage
but I believe you can take fall damage
if you fall from the top to the ground I
happen to find my grenade in a chest it
is unclear to me that this is also on
the floor but I'm just going to assume
that it is and I'm also going to assume
that's it that it's also in supply drops
if it happens to be in a chest the
grenade doesn't have to be an outside
only item you can throw it inside in and
will break all the materials in its way
making it a path so it can build the
base making this for a decent escape
tactic or a cheeky base type of thing on
the side of a building like in tilted
towers in terms of the situation's it's
obviously nice for base defense for when
you're outnumbered and countering ramp
rushers if you're on a materials and you
need a quick base you can chuck down one
of these bad boys for a great defensive
base and allow you to most likely get
the high ground on the opponent
obviously depending on how far up there
it since it's metal your base is gonna
be lasting a pretty long time before it
gets destroyed this is also a nice way
to counter ramp rushers since you can
now be a stair or two higher than them
by simply throwing down the fort and not
wasting any materials on the small case
they are still higher than you putting
down the fort closes the gap making it
easier to fight them then being all the
way from the bottom while they're at the
top you're a little bit
closer now even if you want to charge
them yourself you can build off of the
for like any normal surface so you can
waste less materials and still be higher
than them using the form and this can
also help if you're outnumbered once
again allowing you to get the high
ground on the team outnumbering them and
killing them off if you take anything
from this video it's the fact that high
ground and for tonight is very key to
your survival and this portal 4 can help
achieve that faster than building it
yourself and without wasting materials
for situations you shouldn't use the 4
is early game 1v1 unless it's toward the
end and for healing purposes I know this
sounds a little bit weird so let me
explain these are an epic rarity item
which like I said is purple me and they
aren't always going to be everywhere
throughout the map so you can't really
waste these unless you have a full stack
of 5 then simply just start throwing
those forever you feel but you can
simply win fights in the early game by
ramp rushing someone or just building a
base in general since most people don't
have materials or decent weapons if your
auto materials and that's your last
resort then of course go wild and throw
that [ __ ] on the floor but you should
be saving it for later in the game as
much as possible one of the ones also
fall into this topic since you can't
just move the base wherever you wanted
to once it's placed then that's a waste
if it's for one person building a simple
one by one and you should be just fine
and then lastly is don't use this just
the heal there's no reason to build this
big-ass base just a heal or shield up if
the base is already up and you need to
chug a mini real quick during a fight
that's completely different and that's
completely fine in this instance you're
basically going to be using the base to
heal and that's just a waste of
materials as opposed to you in the
middle of a fight just ducking down
underneath the little ramp portion chaw
gonna mean you're getting a bandage
maybe a med kit while your teammates
suppress fire then you go back into the
fight in terms of tips you can either
edit the door or block the hole in the
middle of your fort to prevent people
from entering unexpectedly I like to do
both since sometimes I accidentally fall
in one a gunfight so all you have to do
is once you get into the fort edited so
that there's no door anymore jump up
with the stairs and build a floor so you
don't fall in and then if people don't
come in
you will hear gunfight before they start
to jump in so you'll definitely have the
jump on them when they start to come up
to your base for my overall thoughts
it's a really nice item and it can be
really powerful at some points but
nothing too crazy since the metal has to
build and it isn't already at full
health this is also really helpful to
new players who aren't really great at
building they need a quick base fast
it's also nice to
waste materials so it's basically a
freebase for the cost of nothing I think
it's completely fine also consider the
fact that it's purple and it won't spawn
as much because of the rarity let me
know what you guys think in the comments
below and as well as if you have any
other tips that I didn't mention also
leave those in the comments below but
that is going to be ended the video
today guys hope you guys did enjoy this
very decently short guide on the portal
for like I said let me know what you
guys think about this weapon I
personally think it's a really nice
addition to the game really is helping
out the new players that don't know how
to build bases as quick and other stuff
like that and can really help you out in
a pinch especially when you're out of
materials but either way like I said
it's going to be end of the video like
the video if you guys did enjoy but it
has helped me out subscriber for new I'm
gonna be posting a lot more fortnight
guides with the upcoming weapons and all
that good stuff coming out my two most
recent videos are going to be on screen
if you guys do want to check those out
and with that guys hope you have a great
rest your day enjoy the new item and
peace out